So, the next thing we need to understand about the problem is what are the
outputs? The statement of the question gives some idea of what the outputs
should be, and then, calculate your age in days part. But it doesn't specify
really explicitly what we want the output to be. So, let's make that a quiz. See
if there's enough information here for you to decide how we should specify the
output. The choices are, print a number, giving the number of days between the
first date and the second date. The second choice is return a number, giving the
number of days between the first date and the second date. And the third choice
is output 3 values, giving the number of years, months and days between the two
input dates. Select the one you think is best.